hi this is J us with movie clips here
with the review of one of the
oscar-nominated documentaries the act of
killing this is directed by Joshua
Oppenheimer who has spent the last few
years in Indonesia actually making
connections so that he could make this
film which is largely about the former
death squad leaders of the 1965 genocide
that took place in the country
unlike most documentaries the act of
killing actually features zero archival
footage or anything of that matter it's
entirely where these people are today
namely Anwar Congo who was once an
executioner and now enjoys his life as a
grandfather among many other activities
Congo himself was responsible for the
death of over a thousand people who died
through the his own hands
and he shows us some of the techniques
which he used to kill various people
what further sets the act of killing
apart from the other documentaries that
we were seeing this year are that the
filmmaker has asked them to recreate a
lot of these heinous killings back in
the day and Moore and his friends were
actually known has movie theater
gangsters and this term gangster is
something they go back to again and
again throughout the film perhaps the
most unnerving thing about this
documentary is seeing the state of
Indonesia today where these men are
heralded as heroes and they're brought
on TV talk shows to talk about some
other famous exploits and where Congo
specifically we see throughout the
course of this documentary undergo a
change when he sees the killings that
he's been asked to recreate and then
watches them in his own living room he
is affected by the violence we often
talk about how violence desensitizes the
youth of our nation but what the act of
killing actually pushes forward is that
it can be a sensitizing act to some
individuals the act of killing is an
unprecedented fell
I think this is one of the most
important films ever made and easily the
best documentary of the year the first
time I saw the act of killing I was
published enough to be there for a Q&A
with Joshua Oppenheimer before the film
he actually stood up and told us it's
okay to laugh when you watch this I
thought that was really strange actually
but he told us that many of the
audience's he has screamed the film with
actually did find it entertaining and
Indonesian audiences laughed at most
this is an impossibly entertaining film
because Anwar and his friends albeit
murderers are quite jolly people to hang
around with and the documentary lets us
into their lives like no other film
could Errol Morris has gone on the
record for say in the last 20 minutes of
this film are the most important thing
ever put on celluloid I would have to
echo his words I think what this film
gets at is absolutely groundbreaking and
how violence affects the human psyche
and the cry for repentance that one can
ultimately have in my estimation the act
of killing is the frontrunner for the
best feature-length Oscar that's been
nominated this year we'll see if it
turns out that way and in the meantime
you can see it for yourself on Netflix
Instant for movie clips this is Jay s
thanks for watching